let's start today with what is more
horrible right-wing news out of Italy
where Italy is Shifting dramatically to
the right as the Associated Press
reports rewarding Maloney's party now
you may say anything Maloney wait you're
talking about Christopher Maloney the
guy from Law and Order no no no no it
has nothing to do with that let me tell
you what's going on in Italy uh the AP
reports a party with neo-fascist roots
the brothers of Italy won the most votes
in Italy's national elections looking
set to deliver the country's first
far-right-led government since World War
II and make its leader Georgia Maloney
Italy's first woman Premier near final
results showed Monday
Italy's lurched to the far right shifts
Europe's geopolitical reality placing a
Euro skeptic party in position to lead a
founding member of the EU and its third
largest economy right-wing leaders
across Europe immediately hailed
Maloney's Victory and her party's
meteoric rise ascending an historic
message to Brussels also a report from
BBC with a similar assessment and
similar analysis Maloney is widely
expected to form Italy's most right-wing
government since World War II now if
you're interested in the specific
policies that Maloney ran on
um and that her party ran on brothers of
Italy certainly take a look at that it
is a more or less standard package of
this yeah some call it right-wing
nationalism
others say it really is neo-fascist now
why has this been happening in Europe
because we've seen it in Hungary we've
seen the rise of these movements in the
Czech Republic and Poland and in many
different places even some of the more
traditionally left-wing countries like
Sweden have seen elements of this
right-wing nationalism rise the story
that is told by The Defenders you've got
your strong Defenders and your soft
Defenders of this right-wing movement
the story they like to tell is a very
similar story to what those in the U.S
like to tell about Donald Trump which is
these individuals have correctly
identified
economic concerns and they've coalesced
those who feel as though they have been
left behind as open border immigration
has been welcomed and on and on and they
said look here I am actually getting a
message that makes sense which is we
need to be it's simply about being for
the people that are here
it's about being you know in the U.S the
story was
we want a guy who's four Americans not
for China
not for the Mexicans coming in through
the border with just he's for Americans
that's what's great about Trump and it's
a very similar story that they like to
tell about the rise of these movements
Hey listen we finally have someone who's
going to speak up for Italians not
Turkish immigrants or Morocco you know
whatever whatever the country is
depending on where in Europe you are
there's nothing wrong with being for the
French or for the hungarians there's
it's it's for us it's good that's the
story that's told however
we know that it's not really about those
economic realities and economic concerns
because we have counter examples you
look two really good examples are the
Czech Republic and Poland
in the Czech Republic in Poland there
has been an improving economic situation
by basically every measure over recent
years and yet support for this
right-wing nationalist
neo-fascist movement has grown in the
Czech Republic and in Poland over those
years so there's two possibilities one
possibility is
even though the economy has been
improving
a lot of people don't realize that and
so they say no we need these right-wing
nationalists now that happens in the
United States people just ignorant of
the reality I mean look at right now in
the United States despite some
indicators not being so good like
inflation we are close to Full
Employment and most economic indicators
are actually quite solid you could have
the same thing in Europe the economy is
improving people don't believe it is so
then they go we need a neo-fascist
that's one possibility second
possibility is it's not really about the
economic stuff and in the United States
under Trump
some people felt that it was the
populist economic message that attracted
them to Trump but we know it was more
than that we know it was if not creating
racism and xenophobia certainly
welcoming it and saying you can all be
part of this movement and so they found
a home with Trump all of these things
were really what was going on and so
propaganda is a huge part of it
um fear is a big part of it we know that
making people afraid leads them to
reactionary political beliefs when
people become fearful they reflexively
say well let's do something about that
fear
uh much like if you were convinced that
there was a really high risk of for
example a home invasion in your
neighborhood you would in a reactionary
way be willing to do all sorts of things
that maybe when you're clear-headed you
wouldn't be willing to do whether it's
buying all sorts of guns or booby
trapping or whatever right I mean you
get the idea fear gets us to act in ways
we would not normally act and so fear
about immigrants from Northern Africa
has been a big factor in Europe Us
Versus Them ideology the European union
doesn't have our best interests in mind
and they're going you know it's similar
to Trump stuff right NATO NATO it
doesn't have our best interest in mind
these coalitions are bad nafta's bad all
this stuff similar sort of sort of idea
so where we end up
is with the first presumably assuming in
the next few hours everything goes as as
it is expected to go
the most right-wing government in Italy
dating all the way back to World War II
scary stuff and we're going to continue
following this right work rightward
Trend I know that many of you who watch
this show also love documentaries if you
don't have curiosity stream you were
missing out our sponsor curiosity stream
is the only streaming platform
specializing in documentaries that's all
they have documentaries and this lets
them deliver the newest and most
critically acclaimed documentaries stuff
you're not going to find on other
streaming services curiosity stream also
has a whole bunch of super high quality
original content you won't find anywhere
else the other night I watched asteroids
comets and meteors as many of you know
I'm super interested in what seems to be
the inevitable direction we are going
which is the eventual mining of
asteroids and to be perfectly Frank I
never remember the difference between
asteroids comets and meteors and that's
one of the things that I learned check
out curiositystreams catalog you'll see
they have a much better selection of
documentaries than the other platforms
they also have an app for your TV phone
tablet and computer and the best part is
my audience gets curiosity stream for
under two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below